last week Senator Josh Hawley spoke to
the national conservatism conference in
Washington he delivered a great speech
legitimately smart and interesting it's
online if you'd like to watch it it's
worth the time so naturally because the
speech was effective the left is coming
out of the woodwork to accuse Hawley of
crime think they're now saying he's an
anti-semite anti-semite why well because
during his speech Hawley accurately
described America's leads as being
global as Cosmopolitan's with no real
attachment to America because they are
everyone knows that nobody thinks
hallease an anti-semite if they did they
probably would have been upset a few
years ago when President Obama said this
now it should be noted that this new
international elite the professional
class that supports them differs and
important respects from the ruling
aristocracy's of old a decent percentage
considered themselves liberal in their
politics modern and cosmopolitan in
their outlook it was true and Obama said
it was true and Senator Holly said it
Senator Holly joins us tonight senator
thanks a lot for coming on did we miss
describe that you're being called an
anti-semite for describing many of our
elites as not attached to the United
States yeah I guess that's right I mean
what I've learned Tucker is that when it
comes to liberals there's only one thing
that they love more than being elitist
and that's accusing everybody else of
being bigots in order to shut down
speech in order to devalue the views of
the American people they say oh you're a
bigot you're a racist because they don't
want to admit what they have done they
don't want to admit what their policies
have done shipping jobs overseas hurting
working families keeping wages flat for
decades that's their legacy and it's
time that they owned it so what you're
saying is that they use cries of bigotry
as a diversion to keep you occupied on
the defensive so you won't notice how
badly they've just managed the country
yeah you know I mean it is strange as
you point out that when Barack Obama
makes the same point that an
international elite that's his word
cosmopolitan and they're out
who are increasingly disconnected he
goes on on that same speech to say this
new elite is disconnected from national
feeling and increasingly disconnected
from the workers who actually make the
products that they depend on who
actually built this country and that's
precisely what I said but the left can't
take that they can't be put on the spot
and they don't want to be called out as
elitist that they truly are and they
don't want to be put on the spot for
their failed policies that have hurt
this country that have hurt the workers
of this country and they don't have
anything to offer and so all we get is
that well you're a bigot you're a racist
as they try to distract from their
failures what's so interesting is the
left is suddenly in the position of
defending the prerogatives of the ruling
class I mean here you are a Republican
taking up for the interests of people
who you know make 40 grand a year and
the rules are saying you know those
people deserve no attention and stop
criticizing George Soros because she
can't be criticized is that weird you
think yeah oh I mean it's it's totally
weird but listen I mean the Liberals are
increasingly the party of the elites I
mean they are the party of the ruling
class and that's the point and that's
what they don't want to admit they are
the ruling class and they have been for
decades they control the commanding
heights in this country the media the
big multinational corporations are
universities I mean they have
effectively run the country the Liberals
have for decades now and their consensus
has given us what we have today I mean
they're the ones who are responsible for
jobs offshoring they're the ones who are
responsible for wages flat for the the
plight and struggle of working Americans
you know working Americans ordinary
Americans in places like where I grew up
in rural Missouri they just want
somebody to speak for them and to be
constantly told that they're bigots and
they're racists and their lives don't
matter and their views don't they're
tired of that well you clearly are did
very quickly did it ever occur to you to
sort of put your head down I mean they
basically hit you right in the face
rhetorically the second you gave that
speech
you don't seem intimidated did did you
ever pause and think ah it's not work
that I'm gonna stop talking like this oh
no because I knew as soon as they were
hitting me that we had hit the nerve and
that we were on the right track I mean I
knew then that what we said was right
and I'm more determined than ever to
speak up for the people who don't have a
voice who have been ignored by the elite
for too long and who by the way
are the backbone of this country amen so
nicely put good for you Godspeed
senator thank you thank you